olivia culpo
who was miss universe
she's one of the most beautiful women on
planet earth olivia culpo showed up to a
flight
to cabo san lucas
wearing a very skimpy outfit she was
wearing a little looked like just a bra
and some extremely tight kind of
leggings and she i think she had a
sweater but it was open and she shows up
and
she looked hotter than a two dollar
pistol there's no question about it and
the stewardess on the flight said you
got to cover up late you got to put a
shirt on or we're not going to allow you
on the flight and she threw a big hissy
fit or her sister or someone in her
family through a big hissy fit about it
i can't believe
i can't believe i'm saying this 12 year
old michael would be very upset with 31
year old michael for saying this
american airlines was right
olivia culpo should
should cover up
people have the right not to be
constantly titillated
every man listening to this show
almo almost every man listening to this
show
has a part of them that would really
like to see olivia culpo wear
extremely tight scandalous clothing to
the to the airport on their there's a
part of of man that wants to see that
but
at least the men who are not just
complete degenerates have another part
to them that that don't want to see that
because we want to read our book or we
want to do our work or we want to have a
conversation and we don't want to be
completely distracted by this bombshell
who's sitting next to us on an airplane
wearing her underwear
you don't because you want to do other
things in your life
but we have forgotten that
because we now live in a culture where
where women actually just wear leggings
as though they're pants and wear bras as
they're their shirts and so we're
constantly titillated all the time and
it is
it is not conducive to a flourishing
society i remember thinking this when i
would take exams sometimes and girls
would show up wearing this kind of
clothing i think this is unfair
because i'm going to do worse on the
exam now because i'm distracted by this
hot girl wearing very little clothing
and she's never going to be distracted
by me
it's not as though i could walk into an
exam wearing my birthday suit and all
the girls would say oh my gosh wow i
can't know they'd probably just ignore
it
this is not conducive to a good society
this is why we have laws against
indecent exposure
right this is why i'm actually not
allowed to walk around in my birthday
suit and people are
generally happy about that i don't know
maybe some people
maybe it titillates them too but we live
in a society
and so the individual right to wear your
underwear in public
it must be
suppressed
for the broader collective right the
community right
the political right
to not constantly be
titillated
that this is something that
the libertarian version of the right
wing in america doesn't
doesn't really get or doesn't really go
along with but the conservative version
of the conservative movement in america
obviously gets
if a woman if a woman dressed like this
in the days of our founding fathers she
would probably be run out of town on the
rail she should probably be called a
witch she'd be run away she they
wouldn't what i'm saying i'm not saying
olivia culpo is a witch he seems like a
lovely lady but
this would not be tolerated
even those great defenders of freedom
the founding fathers the great men who
built our country that's not what
freedom is
freedom to be distracted all the time
is no freedom at all
the reason this stuff should be
encouraged is not because men don't like
them but because men do like them and we
live in a society and we like them a
little too much and we can't have that
hey you
thanks for thanks for being here i'm
glad to see you i always like seeing you
when you come around these parts
unfortunately sometimes our our pals
here in the big tech world don't want to
give you notifications
about these new videos so to maximize
your chance of getting the notifications
ring that bell subscribe also if you
want to get the unvarnished uncensored
too hot for big tech
version of the show head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe for free
and leave a five-star review we'll see
them
[Music]
[Music]